[تصفيق]
احتجاجات متواصله في وجه مراوغات سياسيه
والتفاف على مطالب تحرر المجتمع الايراني
اربعه اشهر على انتفاضه ايران كانت كافيه
لكشف عوار النظام وقرارات سياسيه في اتجاه
وممارسات في اتجاه اخر فبحسب صحيفه
النظام لفرد عقوبات على النساء التي
يخالفن معايير ارتداء الحجاب ليستبدل
الاعتقال بفرض عقوبات قد تصل الى حضر
السفر الدولي ودفع غرامات ماليه
مكتب المدعي العام الايرانيه اصدر توجيهات
جديده للشرطه بالامتناع عن اعتقال النساء
اللائي يخالفن قواعد اللباس النسائيه في
البلاد ولكن بدلا من ذلك فرض عقوبات عليهم
استخدام كاميرات المراقبه الامنيه
الكاميرات المستخدمه لتسجيل المخالفات
المروريه يمكنها تنفيذ هذا العمل بشكل
منهجي لمراقبه النساء اللائي يخالفن قواعد
اللباسه وتجنب اصطدام مباشر اخر بين
الشرطه والمواطنين اذا لم تمر سوى بضعه
ايام على حل شرطه الاخلاق من قبل المدعي
العام الايراني غياب العناصرها في الشوارع
وحضور لكاميرات مراقبه النساء الى جانب
رسائل التهديد على هواتفهن المحموله اما
الوصايه او فرد مزيد من العقوبات
علي السمان العربيه